hi I'm Madison Headrick I'm the founder of
care•e•on and a very frequent flyer today
I'm going to show you my can't live without
products while in Flight I kicked off my shoes
got comfortable in my seat next I opened up my
ccare•e•on kit and used the cleared for takeoff
hand sanitizer before chowing down on some
snacks next I use my liquid IV powder and a
bottle of water for an extra boost of hydration
which is super important while in Flight next
I use the Hydro Boost hydrating pads along with
the flying hydration mask to get my skin really
moisturized and aquifore my lips next I use the
Highline Wellness CBD sleeping gummies and read
a book while I waited for those to kick in
I put on this Monta sleep mask which is my
new obsession it has these little suction cups
on your eyes thank God I slept well I'm waking
up I feel fresh but need to feel fresher so
I'm using the carry-on facial mist and I also
use these energy and focus neuromints along
with the biocast biligent research lip balm
it's also really good all right I'm landing and
off to my meeting in Italy thanks for tuning in